this is 8 news now special edition
it's disgusting the irs needs to sit
down and talk to us like they always
have
hundreds of hospitality workers sending
a message to the irs they say they can't
survive with the current tax rate on the
tips they're making good afternoon
thanks for joining us for this special
edition of eight news now at three i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casadas
demonstrators gathered in downtown today
to speak out against the agency's tax
rate on tips joe muller was there and he
joins us live now on the strip with why
they say this is important joan
thousands of people work right here on
this trip and this is where they make a
living many of them are upset with the
irs saying they're being taxed way too
much on the tips that they make hundreds
gathered outside the federal building
with signs just like this hoping to send
a message to the irs
we want to be able to have a say in this
my paycheck is cut in half i worked 80
hours and made 471 dollars i have
co-workers who are getting no checks at
all the people working in the heart of
las vegas say change needs to happen
aretha wilder is a cocktail waitress at
the flamingo we are not making the money
that we used to make it's just that
simple the culinary union represents 60
000 hospitality workers hundreds
gathered to show their frustration with
how much they are being taxed on their
tips after reducing the tax rate for
tips during the pandemic it went up in
january but workers now say they can
barely survive i'm at a 25 dollars an
hour rate right now so that average is
out 196 dollars a day that i'm taxed on
the rate varies from business to
business julie wolf has been a cocktail
waitress at boulder station for more
than 20 years so no matter what i need
to make that money if i haven't hit that
amount then i'm not making i'm going to
get my that's taken out of my check
regardless both say lowering the rate
would help thousands of valley residents
simply survive gas prices are higher the
housing market is ridiculous in las
vegas i'm paying 1900 a month for my
rent it was 1400 a month they say in the
past they were able to negotiate with
the irs they want to do that again talk
to us sit down and be fair be reasonable
[Music]
back out here live to the las vegas
strip many of those workers you heard
from there were heading to work right
here on the strip right after that
demonstration we also did reach out to
the irs about this demonstration
happening today to see if there was any
sort of comment or to see if there are
plans to negotiate with the culinary
union but we have yet to hear back
reporting live on the las vegas trip joe
mohler live local now